foreign
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together
we're the minimalists we're here with
malabama hi everybody TK Coleman is here
what it is we got the rest of our team
in the studio as well coming up today on
this free public minimal episode we're
talking to a listener about some news
media clutter that they have in their
lives and decluttering some of the
information clutter that they're
struggling with we also have an
outstanding lightning round listener tip
and added value segment for you you can
check out the full two and a half hour
maximal edition of episode 366 where we
answer four times the questions and we
dive deep into several simple living
segments that private podcast episode is
out right now at patreon.com the
minimalists your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel what 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck let's start with our
callers y'all if you have a question or
comment for our show give us a call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at the minimalists.com our first
question today is from Joe hi I'm Joe a
patreon subscriber in the UK and when
talking about phones and addictive apps
I find the news more of a problem I'm in
the UK and as soon as I read about the
threat of nuclear war or of our energy
supplies being cut off
my anxiety goes through the roof and
stays right up there for days but I also
seek this news it's like I obsessively
check the news for these stories I was
the same with covid and any such
disaster or threat I'm not sure whether
I'm trying to get as much information as
possible to protect myself somehow yet
it's really doing the opposite
part of me knows though the only news
worth knowing is that which affects my
immediate community and family sure some
of these things would certainly threaten
that but maybe I would be better off not
knowing I don't understand why I can't
stop looking I block news sites on a
regular basis and always end up
unblocking them it's literally like a
drug
TK you know what's fascinating about
this I've realized this over the last
few years ever since we had you on the
podcast we did a political clutter
episode years ago we brought in was
about it was about the 2020 election
specifically we had the liquor special
we had uh Kim Iverson was here Jamie
kilstein you me and Ryan and we all had
this conversation about the political
landscape and a lot of it was about sort
of news media clutter and what I
realized in preparation for that episode
and I've carried it with me ever since
is that the news is not really designed
to inform
it is designed to get your attention to
attract your attention and I want to say
that information is not inherently good
or bad it's certainly not virtuous and I
think that's the problem that Joe's
running into here is well I'm just
checking in with the media it's the
story I tell myself so I can be more
informed and that will then equal I'm a
more virtuous more noble version of
myself but I think that's not inherently
true because what Joe is figuring out
here is this is increasing my anxiety
it's increasing my stress it's
increasing my discontent and guess what
of course it is because that's what it's
designed to do it's it's designed to
make you feel a way so that you continue
to tune in to whatever channel is making
you feel those feelings
it's a hell of a drug
they know it too yeah I mean she said
it's just as addicting as a drug right
and and that's that's um
that's not by accident right like like
that's engineered it's not as if this
information is just being put out there
neutrally like hey we just collected a
random you know set of stories and we're
gonna put the stories out there and you
decide what's important to take a look
at like no like they are picking their
headlines they are picking the stories
based on what's most likely to get the
engagement by the way you know I just
saw somebody online the other day kind
of complaining about all the negativity
on on uh social media and I was like
yeah but you were tweeting about the
negativity on social media right and I'm
not saying that you're wrong for doing
that but that's engagement and whether
you engage out of love or hate
frustration or Joy it's still engagement
you're still incentivizing the system to
give you more of that so if someone says
Hey like here's a great Dean Martin
quote and another person says Dean
Martin is a total idiot we don't care
about the one that says here's a Great
Dane Martin quote we don't care about
that we want the one that says name
Martin's an idiot so we can fight over
it right and so everything that we
engage we get more of and they're
studying us man like ah you get a
reaction out of that stuff right people
always say I want more positive News why
you got to share me that share with me
the negative stuff it's because you
don't you don't engage that you fall
asleep when they give you that yeah you
actually don't want the positive news I
mean because yeah it doesn't elicit the
reaction that they're looking for I mean
it's it's infotainment and that's it's
just it's information disguised as
entertainment
I'm sorry it's entertainment disguised
as information and yes it's it's
supposed to be informing us right and
yet we're pretending
as though we're getting something out of
it but what we're really getting out of
it is the stress the anxiety the things
it's designed to do it which is bring
our attention away from whatever is
important to us to the things that is
important to them yeah I mean we think
that we're going and doing a good thing
and we're uh looking out for the world
and you know we're staying up on current
events but it's really it's pacification
it it isn't actual research and I'm not
trying to discredit certain things that
you know maybe somebody does want to
look up and look at a bill that's going
to get passed or
um I don't know I mean you know there's
some exceptions out there but if you go
to you know CNN.com foxnews.com
Breitbart whatever it is their goal is
not to
um uh uh give you information their goal
is to really sell you advertisements and
they do that through this information
that either gets you really upset I mean
if you're looking at headlines uh what's
is it the Drudge Report which kind of
Aggregates everything yeah I mean the
headlines are just it's click bait I
mean clickbait uh before the internet it
was it was news headlines and
um yeah it's very easy for us to react
and we get uh motivated to react when we
are angry when we're sad when we're
upset but yeah if we went to the new
site and it was just like oh everything
was nice today and uh this you know so
and so helped so and so across the
street and got them some groceries like
we would get up we would get off that
pretty quick and we also wouldn't be
tweeting about that yeah I would look at
that say boring move me to the thing
that gets my blood pressure up right
yeah and it's the reason that we seek
out scary movies or we seek out action
thrillers is because we are seeking out
entertainment but there in those
instances we know that we're seeking out
entertainment we get really confused by
the news media clutter because it
purports to be one thing oh it's
virtuous information right okay it's
information but information doesn't
presuppose virtue and when we conflate
the two oh I'm being a good citizen I'm
being a good person by staying informed
information is worth next to nothing we
were a meeting last week and uh I hate
ideas
ideas are the worst thing
and here's why I said people always come
to me with ideas oh right and they're
never willing to actually execute on
those ideas to actualize those ideas
it's just like hey here's some work for
you to do Josh I have an idea here you
go and it's like oh your ideas actually
work worth less than nothing because
it's taking up my time now what do I why
is this coming up in this conversation
about news media clutter well because
news media is the same thing it's worth
less than nothing in most instances says
because I can give you more information
your problem is not access to
information you have more access to
information than anyone in history you
have more access to information than any
King from several hundred years ago any
Pharaoh you have way more information
and yet I was talking to Professor Sean
about this earlier today we're more
miserable than ever what do I mean by
that we're suffering more
we're suffering from things that we
don't need to suffer from right like
this sort of nuclear war it's like if if
someone wants it launches a nuke
um I mean what does the information that
it's coming what does that do for you
right I mean
or like you know the gas shortages I
think about the pandemic and how uh yeah
I read about the toilet paper shortage
so I mean luckily like I you know I had
a sink and some washcloths in my
bathroom it's so funny how we freaked
out of her toilet paper so I didn't like
go out and hoard toilet paper but all
those people who went out and hoarded
toilet paper it's like what did I really
get them
that's right yeah and and I well I saw
um I've seen uh like pictures of people
trying to return their hoarded toilet
paper like shortly after the pandemic
and yeah and it's funny because customer
service is like no like that's your
horde now yes yeah so yeah I don't know
how I don't know
um how it helps us to have a heads up on
things like nuclear war or a or a fuel
shortage or whatever it may be if
anything it just kind of causes panic
well and sometimes it's good to focus on
things that make you feel bad but that's
given the Pres presupposition that you
can actually do something about it but
we're focusing on things that both make
us feel bad and that we can't do
anything about right not only that even
if you can't do anything about it and
you just want to be informed that
doesn't mean there's no boundary around
how much information is enough like how
how well do you need to be informed two
hours of listening about the
possibilities of nuclear war five hours
you know um I want to read something
from Terence McKenna who has a very
beautiful YouTube clip called create
your own Roadshow where I think he kind
of gives
um directions for a way out he says this
we have to create culture don't watch TV
don't read magazines don't even listen
to NPR create your own Roadshow the
Nexus of space and time where you are
now is the most immediate sector of your
universe and if you're worrying about
Michael Jackson or Bill Clinton or
somebody else then you are disempowered
you're giving it all away to icons icons
which are maintained by an electronic
media so that you want to dress like X
or have lips like why this is [ __ ]
brained this kind of thinking that is
all a cultural diversion and what is
real is you and your friends and your
associations your highs your orgasms
your hopes your plans your fears and we
are told no we're unimportant we're
peripheral get a degree get a job get of
this get it that and then you're a
player you don't want to even play that
game you want to reclaim your mind and
get it out of the hands of the cultural
Engineers who want to turn you into a
half-baked [ __ ] consuming all this
trash that's being manufactured out of
the bones of a Dying World
the reason we're so addicted to
scrolling to gossip to news stories to
things that are dragging us down is
because if we're honest with ourselves
we're compensating for the total absence
of Thrills and adventure and positive
drama in our own lives we need some
drama we need challenges we need
difficulties to overcome we need a
mission we need a purpose we need
something that gets us out of bed and
makes us feel alive and when we don't
have that we go seeking it in the
entertainment industry we go seeking it
online and arguments and so on and so
it's not good enough to say I'm just
gonna stop watching this stuff I'm going
to stop consuming this stuff you've got
to ask what am I going to start doing
instead in order to get that Adventure
in a way that's healthy
but news media is quite often
disempowering because it makes us feel
like everything else that's going on out
there is important to TK's point
if everything else out there is
important what am I saying that what's
going on in my own life is not important
what's going on in my house is not
important and so what we do is we
abdicate our own responsibility to look
at our lives examine what's going on in
our minds and our hearts and our
households
and if we can fix that not through some
sort of mechanical process but by better
understanding the problem in our own
lives then maybe we can help our
neighbor maybe we can help our
neighborhood maybe we can help our
community but there's not a whole lot I
can do for someone who's 18 000 miles on
the other side of the world yeah I can
worry about them I can have fear I can
punish myself for the troubles that are
going on over there all the while I'm
forgetting about the problems that are
going on in my own backyard
Joe I'd love to send you a copy of our
book essential Ryan and I wrote this
book years ago 2015 is when it came out
150 essays about intentional living
there's 12 different chapters 12
different areas of intentional living
and one of those areas has to do with
our technology there's a entire chapter
in there about our relationship with
technology and how often we use it to
distract ourselves but we can do the
opposite technology can be a tool Ryan
TK and I we're not luddites we're not
saying get rid of your technology get
rid of the news but if you better
understand
how to use it when it is useful to you
then you'll stop using it in a way that
you're battering yourself with your own
technology if you like our podcast I
think you'll enjoy the audiobook version
of essential or if you want the book or
the ebook version we'll be happy to send
those to you as well Joe it's Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it's
time for the lightning round now Jordan
Jordan's gonna put some really cool
effects in right there uh this is where
we answer your questions from social
media yes indeed you can follow the
minimalists on Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook and Twitter at the minimalist
we used to answer these questions via
text message but as you heard on our
last episode
365 we stopped doing the text message
thing because we don't negotiate with
terrorists
looks like LC has a question for us from
Alabama how do we become more
psychologically flexible so we can
increase our capacity for happiness now
during the lightning round this is where
we do our best to answer questions with
a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you'd like
you can find all of those minimal maxims
over in the show notes at the
minimalists.com
podcast Professor Sean put 60 seconds on
the clock for me LC
rigidity forms a container for
discontent and I am speaking from
experience I am Mr Ridgid I am
I
I like to be more Wiggly whenever I can
I certainly have
have become more flexible as your
question asks
psychologically flexible because
emotionally flexible
intellectually flexible because as I
become more rigid and I need things to
be exactly this way as a person with OCD
I want everything to be just right every
single time in this order in this
sequence I need it to be like this it
stresses me out it makes me miserable
but if I can let go of some of that
rigidity I could become more
free-flowing then it makes room for
contentment
yeah
are you with me okay I'll go all right
hi all right
professor John
put 60 seconds on the clock
um
happiness is a byproduct of living a
meaningful life so
flexible
uh flexible what do they call it
oh my goodness uh psychology is
psychologically flexible here's what I
think about that
um let's say this is my psychology this
class right here okay
um the question presupposes that I could
somehow make this glass bigger
and and I don't agree with that I think
that the glass that you have is the
glass that you have there's a little bit
of water in this glass and so if I want
to put more in there I've got to ask
myself what do I need this water in this
glass right now what else do I want to
put in here but trying to make your uh
psychology more flexible I I don't think
it's a matter of that as much as like
what are you putting into that and do
you need to get rid of anything
love it okay so mine is the goal isn't
happiness it's emotional versatility
the point isn't to exist in a Perpetual
state of always feeling good it's about
learning to relate to the full range of
the emotional Spectrum in a way that's
healthy in a way that's harmonious in
the same way that you don't want to be
the kind of person who can only dance to
one type of song or one genre of music
you want to be the kind of person who
can find your groove and establish a
rhythm no matter what the feeling is
think of it like the seasons right
you've got fall you've got winter you've
got summer you've got spring sometimes
you don't want it to be cold but it is
sometimes you don't want it to be rainy
because you want it to have a picnic but
there's something that you can do in any
kind of weather you can't go to a picnic
when it's snowing but you can go
sledding and the summer doesn't allow
you to do that right so the four
questions I want you to ask is what am I
feeling
how is it serving me what is it teaching
me and how can I express it creatively
and constructively
in just a minute he did it what we're
really talking about there TK and Ryan
is when we're being more flexible it
allows us to let go because we're
accepting the circumstances that are
right there in front of us we've got so
much more to talk about we're gonna
we're gonna dive into TK's home it's a
little bit of an intervention here with
all these throw pillows that he has oh
I'm so excited
every week on the private podcast we do
a home tour where we go into one of our
homes we're going to be looking TK moved
back to California recently we've got
some photos of his new living space
we're gonna dive into that we also got I
think obsolete objects we have oh we're
going to talk about boot licking as a
spiritual practice I got a new rule for
you guys as well I call it the hate that
thing rule and uh you're actually going
to be a little bit surprised by what
that actually means but um we'll dive
into that on the private podcast as well
obsolete objects advertisements suck a
whole bunch more for you over there as
well but first Alabama what do you got
for us here's a minimalist Insight from
one of our listeners hey this is Jane in
Los Angeles I used to have a lot of
trouble making decisions um and now
whenever I go out to
go out to the pick and making quick fast
decisions has helped me get better and
more comfortable with making decisions
in other parts of my life all right
y'all before we get to our added value
segment real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists in less than
two weeks on November 27th Sunday
November 27th at noon we have our final
Sunday Symposium of the year it's here
in Los Angeles who knows this might be
our final ever Sunday Symposium we
haven't decided whether or not going to
renew this or how we're going to process
it going forward we've learned a lot
from the first three events this is our
fourth one where we meet a small group
of people it's 200 people half the
tickets are free by the way I mentioned
this right now because you'll want to go
today to sundaysymposium.com get your
ticket before it sells out every time we
mention on the podcast the tickets go
fairly quickly and because this is the
last one that we're doing this year
maybe ever they'll go really quickly and
if you want to be part of this historic
event well you have the opportunity
Sunday symposium dot com we meet at noon
on Sunday 200 of us and we haven't
experience together we talk about
simplifying Our Lives we talk about
letting go we answer your questions we
do a reading we talk about material
possessions or careers or financial
clutter or information clutter any of
the Clutter that you have in your life
you can bring to this event and we'll
help you sort through that clutter to
figure out what does add value and what
doesn't what's getting in the way and
we'll help you let that go but we'll let
go together
all right added value y'all I got two
things for you the Sedona Method so hail
dwelled skin as I talked about on the
private podcast he was supposed to be
here today couldn't make it we'll get
him on a future episode we talked a lot
on the private podcast about releasing
about letting go of some of these things
that are in the way and I even gave you
the four-step method that Hale uses in
this book the Sedona Method to let go to
release the anxiety the tension to hold
on to it for a minute to recognize it so
you can hear that on the private podcast
or you can just check out the book it's
called the Sedona Method I'm in the
middle of it right now I'm so enjoying
this book it's helping me Let Go not of
physical things I I can let go of those
things easily but some emotional clutter
that I didn't even realize that I had
he's helping me let go of that and
really
find that emotional well-being that is
there once you let go of the tension the
stress the worry the anxiety the
discontent that we've been clinging to
not even knowing we're clinging to it
and so we didn't exercise on the private
podcast you can check that out uh but
check out the book it's called the
Sedona Method and malabama has something
for us if you just want to check the
book out from your local library you use
something called the Libby app can you
talk about that oh my stars I really
enjoy the Libby app Professor Sean and I
were getting giddy over this because
it's so easy to access resources like
ebooks audiobooks magazines from your
library that you probably already use
all you have to do is download the app
that is free it is provided by overdrive
and what they do is connect you to the
digital resources through your library
card you can even add multiple library
cards which is something I didn't know
until Professor Sean even brought up so
I have access to stuff in Illinois in
Tennessee and in Los Angeles oh it's
beautiful and best of all there's not a
single ad on there and you don't have to
read in the app as well you can send the
ebooks to your Kindle if you have a Kobo
uh the service is actually directly
integrated with the device you don't
even need the app uh oh it's on Wow and
so if you want any of the minimalist
books you can check them out at uh the
Libby app as well or I assume the Sedona
Method you could find over there as well
so check it out we'll put a link to that
as well as the Sedona Method in the show
notes so you can check out books for
free ebooks and it sounds like
audiobooks as well right oh yeah that's
where I get most of my audio books you
can get that from your local library
without even going to your local library
game over by the way TK we got a bunch
more surprise questions this week on the
private podcast like how can I declutter
the residue of my ex from my life how
can I minimize the amount of worry I
experience every day
how do I let go of needing the approval
of others to be happy also got a million
more questions for the minimalist and if
you want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast at
patreon.com the minimalist or click the
link in the description that's our show
for today if you leave here today with
just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time peace
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it